[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la Copa
Mundial de la FIFA Qatar 2022 a
continuación nuestros titulares
España se vio inmensa los jóvenes le
respondieron a Luis Enrique y
protagonizaron una goleada de Escándalo
la mayor del mundial sobre Costa Rica
detalles con nuestro enviado especial
los pronósticos siguen cayendo Alemania
fue sorprendida por un Japón ordenado y
ambicioso que no dejó pensar a los
tetracampeones
courtois en plan de héroe el portero del
Real Madrid lo tapó todo en la victoria
de Bélgica sobre Canadá los
norteamericanos dominaron pero el oficio
de los Diablos Rojos resolvió tenemos
análisis
para analizar el acontecer de cada
jornada Contamos con la presencia de
Octavio usazo periodista de la emisora
Blu radio en Colombia bienvenido Octavio
Hola ahumar un gusto saludarte y estar
de nuevo contigo vamos a comenzar con
información de esta
primera goleada del Campeonato Mundial
la sangre joven le ha dado resultado a
España una España con dos adolescentes
en cancha Y con muchos nombres nuevos en
su alineación demolió a Costa Rica en su
primer partido demostrando que la
arriesgada puesta de Luis Enrique
pensando en el futuro están viendo una
solución para el presente desde Qatar
nos cuenta los detalles de la goleada
nuestro enviado especial Juan pupiales
paseo de España en su Debut en esta copa
mundo Victoria para la roja por 7 a 0
contra Costa Rica aquí en este estadio
el estadio altumama de Qatar cerrando
Torres por partida doble asensio Daniel
olmon Carlos Soler Gaby y Álvaro morata
fueron los autores de esta goleada
histórica para la roja que nunca había
conseguido tantos goles en un partido de
mundial además de la mano de su gol
número 100 al que consiguió Daniel olmo
para abrir la lata partido dominado por
la roja de principio a fin con Luis
Enrique el seleccionador español
combinando la veterania de jugadores
como Jordi Alba o Sergio busquet de este
último el único superviviente el único
integrante de esa conquista en 2010 de
la Copa mundo combinando esto con la
juventud de jugadores como Nico como
Pedro y como balde que ninguno de ellos
supera los 20 años y que estuvieron
jugando hoy como Auténticos veteranos en
este encuentro esta Victoria deja a
España con un panorama favorable pero
con una próxima cita este domingo muy
dura contra Alemania Alemania que viene
de perder contra Japón en la jornada en
el partido sorpresa de la jornada Los
Hermanos saben que una derrota contra la
roja en este domingo prácticamente que
sería su adiós de esta cita mientras que
España sabe que sumar ya 6 puntos
seguirá tener pie y medio en las en los
octavos de final de este torneo Costa
Rica por su parte se queda también en
una situación complicada se enfrentan a
los nipones conscientes de que necesitan
sumar para continuar con vida en este
mundial de Qatar 2022
Octavio mucho se dijo cuando se ensambló
este equipo que Luis Enrique Estaba
dejando fuera por ejemplo a Jorge
Iglesias que era el goleador de la liga
o que un hombre como Sergio Ramos tenía
que ser un referente
indispensable independientemente del
estado de forma en que estuviera Pero
estos resultados parecen estar dando
respuesta a esa crítica podemos decir
eso La verdad humar es que digamos Luis
enriquece la jugó con un grupo de
jugadores muy jóvenes que él digamos ha
ido manejando en los últimos tiempos
conoce muy bien su grupo y al final le
termina saliendo su su apuesta Más allá
de que enfrente estaba un rival que hoy
se vio muy diezmado un rival que no está
a la altura del equipo español lo decía
Luis Fernando Suárez una lástima el
técnico colombiano precisamente que
dirige a la selección de Costa Rica
decía que tú no le puedes ganar a España
a un rival de esta categoría si no
tienes la misma calidad técnica de
individual que que tiene Tu rival y la
verdad es que es así Más allá de que sea
un bloque colectivo de que España tenga
un gran plantel en cuanto a la al
talento de los jugadores porque tiene
nombres muy jóvenes y poco conocidos
España apostó al talento individual y le
terminó sacando
rédito a eso la jerarquía algunos de sus
jugadores como Gaby por ejemplo y y a
Sergio busquen la mitad de la cancha que
con su experiencia manejó todos los
siglos Entonces le salió la apuesta Luis
Enrique termina sacándose una una
sonrisa y evitando la crítica de todo el
periodismo español que estaba a la
espera de cualquier desliz de Luis
Enrique y precisamente Esa era la otra
consulta o la otra la otra duda que
tenía hasta qué punto podemos leer este
resultado como
producto de las fortalezas que España va
a mostrar de aquí al resto del
Campeonato del mundo o digamos una
consecuencia de la debilidad del rival
que encontró al frente no es una
combinación yo creería de las dos cosas
porque en principio yo creo marque Costa
Rica no es tan mala como la que hoy
perdió 7 a 0 yo pude haber a Costa Rica
muchas veces en la eliminatoria de
Centroamérica y la verdad es que el
equipo de Luis Fernando Suárez juega
mucho mejor que esto pero se encontró
con un rival que apostó y que tuvo el
mejor partido posible es decir la mejor
tarde de España fue la que terminó
funcionándole y cayéndole la cara al
equipo costarricense y por el otro lado
la puesta de Luis Enrique esto
seguramente le generará le va a generar
España un envío nanímico muy importante
que puede ser El Punto de partida para
que España vuelva otra vez a a gobernar
en medio de este camino como lo hizo ya
en la Liga de Naciones en la que terminó
perdiendo la final con con Francia
entonces puede ser el envión que
necesita el grupo para sentirse
fortalecido evitar las críticas que
vienen muy fuertes desde España y a
partir de ahí generar el fútbol que hoy
que hoy vimos que hizo el equipo hispano
en ese mismo grupo El ese produjo la
gran sorpresa de la jornada La derrota
de Alemania ante Japón abrió segundo
gran de penal y los hermanos lucieron
inmensos en el primer tiempo pero en el
curso de 8 minutos en el segundo los
nipones sentenciaron con Richard
como decía esta mañana nuestra enviada
especial Natalia Ruiz cuando conversaba
en las en los noticieros del matutinos
fue el ipon de Japón Pero podemos decir
Octavio que antes de ese ivón hubo unos
cuantos Wasabi que se marcaron como para
continuar con los términos de judo no
por supuesto la verdad es que hoy todo
el mundo evidentemente eumar lo califica
de sorpresivo pero es que aquellos que
estamos siguiendo el fútbol desde hace
un tiempo sabemos es decir nadie
apostado y sabía que Japón le iban a
Alemania no me voy a cargar esa eso
ahora encima lo que quiero decir es que
sabemos del talento que tiene un país
que viene trabajando en función de Esto
hace más de 40 a 50 años El Talento
individual de Los japoneses ya está a
niveles muy importantes en Europa
jugadores que tienen digamos competencia
en equipos realmente de nivel y la
selección japonesa terminó como bien
dice como bien decías en término de
ayuda dando ese mortal y justo en el
momento en el que Alemania no levantaba
la cabeza fue muy inteligente Japón
terminó generando la la digamos el
movimiento
letal para conseguir el espacio y
terminar llevándose una victoria que que
es histórica definitivamente para el
fútbol de ese país es precisamente sobre
esa capacidad de leer el el partido le
quería Consultar los dos goleadores
venían desde la banca es un mérito de
moriazo El técnico saber leer las
necesidades del partido saber Buscar la
herramienta que necesitaba en ese
momento y Y definitivamente dar vuelta
esto totalmente hoy Estaba leyendo un
par de cosas que tenían que ver con
Japón en las que decían por ejemplo que
minamino que recientemente había jugado
en el Liverpool y es una de las
referencias estuvo en el banco de los
suplentes y él fue el que entró para
para generar una de las jugadas le
habían pedido el técnico le había pedido
a ellos que entraran digamos con esa
disposición sobre el el final del
partido Para aprovechar
solo la digamos la claridad que iban a
tener ese banco de suplentes sino la
energía en función del desgaste que
tenía Alemania lo leyó perfectamente el
técnico de Japón le salió No
necesariamente la tiene que salir
siempre Pero esta vez le salió porque
Alemania se distrajo Alemania Le entregó
el partido en un momento a Japón y Japón
con su disciplina Porque si bien Eso es
cultural con su disciplina terminó
pasándole por encima un rival de tanta
jerarquía ayer veíamos a nueve a un
equipo de Arabia Saudita sorprendiendo
la Luis celeste con nueve jugadores del
álginal que es un equipo dirigido por un
argentino Ramón Díaz Hoy estamos viendo
en Japón Qué le pasa por encima a una
Alemania donde juegan ocho de sus
jugadores donde militan ocho de sus
jugadores en la Bundesliga este tipo de
referencias pueden ser consideradas
válidas en el fútbol tan globalizado de
hoy en día o son simples anécdotas ahora
no Claro que sí claro que sí Fíjate lo
de lo de Ramón Díaz Ramón Díaz Incluso
le había apostado un jeque que
ganar Argentina es decir él aseguraba y
y evidentemente tener a esos jugadores
todos los días indicándoles Cómo juegan
los argentinos evidentemente le genera
digamos algo pero el de hoy El Triunfo
de Japón con tantos jugadores en la
Bundesliga es es mucho mejor es decir
Los japoneses entienden perfectamente el
fútbol en el que están jugando la
selección alemana tiene muchos jugadores
en el Torneo local Entonces cuando van
los japoneses a enfrentarlo no tiene
ningún tipo de asombro cuando enfrente
tienen esos jugadores de la Bundesliga
porque normalmente los ven en el Torneo
local es decir Los japoneses perdieron
ese miedo ese miedo escénico y los
enfrentaron de de tú a tú con la
categoría que tienen con estos
resultados España está cómoda En la cima
del grupo e con Japón además en una muy
buena posición para cumplir esa
proyección inicial de llegar más lejos
que nunca en un Campeonato del mundo y
courtois fue Bélgica Canadá apabulló a
los Diablos Rojos 22 disparos a Puerta
obligaron al portero del Real Madrid
resolver INE extremo y varias veces
incluyendo un penal Bélgica llegó poco
pero allí resolvió en Natalia Ruiz
giraldo nuestra compañera estuvo
presente en ese partido le damos la
bienvenida a Natalia un gusto tenerla en
Diario del mundial y le preguntamos fue
un resultado que dejó más dudas que
certezas no solamente por el ganador
sino por la actuación arbitral es así
así humano muy buenas noches pues
efectivamente dudas de ese árbitro que
ya nos había dejado momentos memorables
durante la carne en ese partido entre
túnez cuando ella quitó dos veces el
final del partido a pesar de que aún no
se habían cumplido los 90 minutos
reglamentarios el día de hoy puede
decirse que de hecho hubiera podido
pitar dos penales más a favor de Canadá
uno en el minuto 14 donde él
supuestamente vio un fuera del lugar que
en realidad parece en realidad que no
existió y luego en el minuto 38 hay un
contacto bastante claro de wixel sobre
la idea y ese penal pues Tampoco tampoco
lo lo Pita en cuanto a las dudas la
certezas de las que usted me está
preguntando pues se quedan muchas dudas
en cuanto a el en cuanto a la posición
que tiene Roberto Martínez de dejar a
Eden nazar como capitán a pesar de que
no fue una muy mala presentación Lo
cierto es que hacer parecía casi
transparente sobre ese terreno de juego
muchas dudas también sobre
que no brilla en este tipo de Bélgica
como si lo hace con a Manchester City y
por supuesto pues esos cambios que hizo
ya sobre la final del partido
que entran allá en algún momento que
tampoco dan una mayor dinámica a este
equipo y pues muchísimas preguntas
quedan muchísimas dudas las certeza es
que esta no es la Bélgica que vimos Hace
cuatro años en Rusia esa Bélgica que
quedó tercera en ese mundial Y
muchísimas preguntas Entonces como les
decía sobre todo antes pues que Bélgica
siga en este mundial y a pesar de todo A
pesar de esa presentación que pues la
verdad de hubiera podido ser red de
pronto peor incluso ante una Canadá
bastante combativa pero muy deficiente
en cuanto a profundidad pues se queda
por ahora con los a tres puntos muy
importantes en este grupo Natalia
hablábamos del ganador que dejó Tantas
dudas pero también toca hablar de ese
perdedor que dejó
digamos una una buena imagen más allá de
la dificultad para concretar estamos
hablando de un equipo que va a ser sede
una de las cosedes del mundial dentro de
cuatro años podemos pensar que este es
el grupo base para emprender esa
aventura
bien puede ser lo que estamos hablando
también de de una Canadá que tiene al
jugador de más edad quizás ya de aquí
allá pues este jugador ya de 39 años no
esté puede ser sí un equipo Pues que
sirva como base ha sido también un
equipo que ha tenido una muy buena muy
buena Progreso este equipo de Canadá que
pues se clasificó primero en la Concacaf
que tuvo Victoria sobre México Victoria
sobre Estados Unidos pero realmente ante
lo que vimos esta noche aquí en este
estadio frente a Bélgica Todavía falta
mucho en cuanto a definición demasiadas
oportunidades para los canadienses de
poder lograr el empate ese penalti de
Alfonso Davis que no está cobrado a la
altura de lo que debería hacer a la
altura de lo que nos ha tenido digamos
acostumbrados y sobre todo teniendo en
cuenta que frente a él estaba un Arquero
como chivo courtois que por lo general
ese una persona un jugador que en
realidad muy pocos errores comete y pues
él quizá tuvo la mejor lucidez de de ese
cobro así que pues bien puede servir
como el equipo base además para ese
momento pues ya llegará con el bagaje
que deja la presentación de este equipo
aquí en este mundial pero en todo caso
esos errores del día de hoy bien pueden
pasarle una factura mucho más delicada a
Canadá en todo caso en este mundial
Natalia Le agradezco muchísimo por su
aporte de este día mañana seguimos con
más
bien Octavio Nosotros también hemos
visto en esta jornada dos caras muy
distintas de la Concacaf la cara que
mostró Costa Rica Aunque usted nos
aclaraba que No necesariamente es
digamos el verdadero rostro de Villano
de este equipo y el rostro por lo menos
pujante y ambicioso que mostró Canadá
Cuál es la verdadera cara de esta región
que es tan polémica yo creería que que
es un es un balance de de las dos cosas
que vimos hoy por un lado equipos
digamos con con mucho talento individual
sobre todo la mitad de la cancha hacia
arriba equipos con potencias juveniles
con con físico que que digamos que se
atreven que ya perdieron y vuelvo a usar
la palabra el miedo escénico que tenían
en algún otro momento la confederación
del Caribe cuando normalmente no tenían
a jugadores en en el gran nivel hoy es
hoy es diferente si si uno analiza hoy
el plantel de la selección canadiense y
evidentemente su gran líder en el Bayern
Munich y a pesar de que hoy
lastimosamente no pudo marcarle con la
courtois evidentemente Alfonso Davis
guía una generación que estoy de acuerdo
contigo edumar que va a ser protagonista
en el mundial de 2026 seguramente porque
están trabajando a la par de la mls de
los Estados Unidos y van prácticamente
en el mismo camino el otro lado Costa
Rica le pasó Le termina pasando factura
a una generación que está entre entre
digamos disputar el mundial y de salida
tiene jugadores como Celso Borges o
Brian Ruiz que se están despidiendo como
Keylor Navas que no se sabe en En qué en
qué momento estará Su futuro que además
tenía tantos días sin sin jugar sin
porque no está siendo titular en el psg
entonces había muchas dudas sobre ese
equipo y Lamentablemente vivieron una
noche horrible pero que estoy seguro no
no representa al fútbol de Costa Rica
Cerramos el repaso de la jornada con el
empate sin goles entre el subcampeón de
Hace cuatro años Croacia y un Marruecos
que tuvo el gran mérito de frenar a Luka
modric y cortarle a las líneas de
comunicación con la delantera croata por
ahí se puede decir que se rescató este
punto con el que salieron los africanos
sí que volvemos a lo mismo Hoy está
Marruecos tiene al menos dos o tres
jugadores que juegan en los mejores
equipos del mundo Entonces cuando tienes
aquí mi tienes así Che tienes jugadores
que pueden ir mano a mano contra el el
rival que sea tiene una ventaja Es
cierto que hay que acomodarse como
selección o como equipo y que enfrente
tenían a un rival que está liderado nada
menos que por lucro Luka modric que
cuando anda en un buen día puede lograr
la magia que él quiera pero lo de
Marruecos es muy destacable eso hizo un
gran negocio incluso pudo haberle
amargado el día a Croacia y termina
llevándose un muy buen punto frente a un
rival que es durísimo y que como bien
dices es la subcampeona del mundo
Octavio Mil gracias por haber estado con
nosotros nos encontramos de nuevo mañana
nos encontramos y ese grupo F queda
liderado por Bélgica pero con las
opciones abiertas para cualquiera de los
equipos como lo comentaba Octavio sazo
vamos con una selección de noticias de
esta Copa del Mundo Alemania no pudo
usar el brazalete arcoiris pero encontró
su manera de protestar hoy contra la
prohibición y demostrar su solidaridad
con la comunidad lgbti las bocas tapadas
en señal de que han debido silenciarse y
una declaración en sus redes sociales
los Derechos Humanos no son negociables
en defensa árabe ya será el shaarani fue
trasladado a Alemania en un jet privado
del heredero al Trono Saudita Mohamed
salman esto luego de la fractura de
maxilar y sangrado interno que sufrió
por el rodillazo accidental de su propio
Arquero en la victoria sobre Argentina
ya será operado
se acabó el mundial para Lucas Hernández
El defensa de la selección francesa se
rompió el ligamento cruzado anterior de
la rodilla derecha en menos de 10
minutos de juego en el partido contra
Australia se une a la legión de
lesionados del campeón del mundo
con esta información les decimos Hasta
mañana seguimos con mucho más de la
actualización del mundial de Qatar 2022
y los invitamos a continuar con la
programación de Francia 24
[Música]